she's a singer-songwriter actress and
filmmaker she's one of the best-selling
artists of all time worldwide with over
245 million records sold
she's the only recording artist to have
a number one album in each of the last
six decades
she's Barbra Streisand and here are her
top 10 rules for success a man's reach
should exceed his grasp it's just life
is a carousel
life is a bowl of cherries I don't know
it's it's life is short and you just got
a play dance experiment fail succeed
learn give in life it's like you know
follow your bliss if you're following a
path that is pleasurable to you it's
much easier its flows it's there's a
life behind the eyes you know there's
there's a shine within it's beyond it's
it's not just work it's it's a joyous
experience it's a you long for that as I
got older I just thought too many people
said to me how could you not sing in
public like we as your fans really want
to hear you and see you live and I
thought I owe this to them
then maybe I owe it to myself to to to
build up the courage to try it again
because it's not about perfection as you
know you know this could happen your
voice could go flatter than and there is
a certain excitement to that and a
certain acceptance again of you know
imperfections my mother had a great
voice not like mine not like my sister's
not like my son a high soprano voice but
like a bird I mean really beautiful but
I used to say mom you know why didn't
you try to get a career as a singer no
she said she was too shy she couldn't do
it and I'm basically shy too but there
that that makes the difference you know
how do you succeed if you don't try the
truth is I think for years I thought
well I don't want to disappoint people
you know it's like it's like you have
this thing for me well if you meet me
you know will you be disappointed will
destroy the mystique now as you get
older you and when you accept your own
imperfections there's a there's a warmth
to that that's like the Indian sewing
and they flow in the blanket you know
that it shouldn't be perfect so I really
can't make a mistake because if I accept
my flaws then you will accept my flaws
exactly music is is transporting music
elevates life you know music is larger
than life you know when you're when you
have certain emotions that are larger
than life you want to sing you want to
you want to express it in a larger way
music is so powerful to the soul it's so
rich and being able to identify with
feelings
music can transport
so it's very strong you had a lot of
people say you were never gonna make it
beside your mom yeah and what did you
think in your head when I'd say I
thought they were crazy same thing with
me that's what I did
no I mean I thought I knew their what
they would meant I I knew why they
thought that but isn't that funny that
that's within enormous insecurity and
doubt was a kind of knowing and knowing
that you know if I stick to my guns and
I tell the truth and I I will be there I
don't know I never thought about it that
much it was something so deep I guess
that uh I tell people some people ask me
another do you think I should be an
actress and and I say boy if you have to
think about it
don't be it now I can direct people know
I can direct now I can write songs
people don't I can write songs I don't
need to do that anymore
I I do bore myself a lot you know I have
to go on and it's not conquer I don't
know if I'd use the word conquer it's
it's expanding one's horizon you know
it's it's trying something new
it's risking failure it's even that's
exciting to me you see actually you have
to be thankful for people like that
because in a way they gave you more
courage that gave you more energy
a more sand more of a sense of your own
destiny it's true
I thank my mother actually for not
believing in me because I really set out
to prove to her that I that she was
wrong and that I I could make something
of my life you know as an actress I am
proud to say I am but there is no such
thing as perfection and I found that out
when I was 15 years old I wrote it in my
journal that perfection is imperfection
so it has that humanity my human quality
otherwise it's too cold right you could
just strive for perfection better word
is excellent strive for excellence
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because al
interpretations asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which a Barbra
Streisand's top-10 rules most resonated
with you leave it in the comments and
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon